más de 3 millones de refugiados
ucranianos el éxodo más masivo y que a
mayor velocidad aumenta desde la segunda
guerra mundial el drama de 19 días de
invasión rusa reflejado en los rostros
de los más pequeños al menos 14 millones
de niños cada minuto 55 menores huyen
del país we are o más sin cese que
comenzó la guerra el 24 de febrero cada
segundo un niño se ha convertido en
refugiados fuera de ucrania rise kent
acnur informó que cerca del 90% del
éxodo está formado por mujeres y niños
también miles de ancianos han logrado ir
portando poco más de lo opuesto porque
los ataques rusos no dan tregua y se
ensañan cada vez más contra objetivos
civiles
en heart cop da mucho miedo todo está
bombardeado la ciudad está destruida no
hay edificios ni casas el centro de la
ciudad ha sido destruido han atacado
barrios residenciales todo ha
desaparecido mucha gente se está
marchando ahí sólo queda una cuarta
parte de la población
es más de 18 millones de personas se han
dirigido a polonia el principal receptor
de refugiados ucranianos miles más han
cruzado las fronteras con hungría
rumanía o moldavia también se estima que
hay 19 millones de desplazados internos
al otro lado de las fronteras
voluntarios y ong se dan refugio y
alimentos como estos taxistas españoles
que se trasladaron hasta polonia para
ofrecer sus servicios a los ucranianos
la gente está volcada hemos tenido
muchísima ayuda muchísimo
muchísimos colaboradores a nivel
particular
yo me queda un poco vamos directamente
desbordado por qué porque conocidos
amigos cuando se han enterado incluso a
los clientes en el taxi que se lo
contaba se han volcado con él con el
tema el pasado 3 de marzo el bloque
europeo acordó ofrecer protección
temporal a la refugio ucranianos
mientras de acnur prevé que de continuar
el conflicto el éxodo podría superar las
4 millones de personas